this is the first one i'm gonna do it's
a classic circular arrangement this one
and it's got some conditions to it
so that's why it's worth having a look
at and i um
i want you to see the way i want to try
and model for you the way i think about
it
and um and also set up my working okay
i can guarantee as i go through this
you'll be like really i
do that much working and my answer to
you for that question is the same as my
answer always is
uh you can get away with less working
but i don't rate your chance of success
getting the right answer as very high if
you do significantly less
okay so if you um can pull
back to exercise 10i or if you're in it
already in it at the moment
question 11 bit of a way through let's
have a look at it together
and you can see this is my summary and
we'll talk through how the summary is
what the question is a sports committee
consisting of four rowers three
basketballers and two cricketers
sits at a circular table how many
different arrangements of the committee
are possible
if the rowers and basketballers both sit
together in groups
so all the rows together all the
basketballs together as
separate groups and no rower
sits next to a basketball so they're in
groups right
but i want the groups to be separated
from each other
does that make sense growers
basketballers they're a group but they
can't actually be adjacent
okay so here's the setup those are all
of the conditions
let's have a think about this now being
that you've got
step one rowers and basketballers in
groups okay
i'm going to think of each of them as
their own object and then i'll work out
what's happening
inside the object later on okay so that
means i've got
around the table i've got one object two
objects
three four does that make sense four
objects to place
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
having got that in my head
is i'm going to draw myself a circular
table
and there are going to be one two three
four positions around the table does
that make sense
okay four positions four things to put
in those positions
and then i start to think about the
conditions that i've been given okay
so for starters the rollers and
basketballers they're in groups
okay now remember it's around a circular
table so at the moment let's imagine the
group of rowers they're walking up
and everything looks the same at the
moment right that group
can sit in any of those spots and it's
it's all identical okay
so let's fix the rowers in a position
okay so i'm going to
there's a whole bunch of them right i'm
going to fix them
up here okay so i'm actually going to
write
fix the rowers in position
okay now i can start thinking about
arrangements
but the conditions are still playing out
in my head okay i notice
that if another group comes along for
example say the basketball is right
how many options in those four um
spots can they go into the the
basketballers
there's only one spot they can go in
right because this option's out
this option is out because they can't
sit next so therefore the basketballers
have to be here
does that make sense
so so far i only have one arrangement
right because remember the rowers all
look the same so i just locked them in
spot
the basketballers have to sit here right
so i'm going to say
only one position
for the basketballers
full stop okay and then lastly i've got
two
final people to place right they're the
cricketers
do they have to sit in either those
spots like there's one quicker to come
along
right the first cricketer and say i have
to sit here or i have to sit there
he doesn't right he can sit in one of
two positions so another way i can think
about that
is i've got two boxes and i can fill
them with either the cricketers and they
don't mind does that make sense
so i've got a cricketer here i've got a
cricketer here there are two factorial
ways
to place the cricketers does that make
sense
i normally would have three factorial
because it's around the circle four
objects
but because of the conditions it's only
two factorial those are the really only
the
guys i'm placing okay so there are two
factorial ways
to seat the picketers
okay lovely so i have all of the objects
around the table
what's left to consider
okay so i've um i've done this tick
right i've done i've placed the actual
you know
rows and basketballs but i haven't dealt
with the actual groups themselves
because they can shuffle around within
the groups and that will be different
arrangements
okay so um how many rolls are there
again
four rowers okay so the rowers
can rearrange themselves so they're
their own little arrangement
and remember look they're placed now
right so that's
going to be one two three four spots so
how many weights
four factorial one okay
for the basketballers
how many basketballs three so three
factorial weighs
have i accounted for everything in the
question
look carefully all the people are in a
spot
the groups have been sorted the
conditions have been met looks good
so the lovely thing about this is you
can see and sometimes i even do this
with another color
right one two factorial four factorial
three factorial all the numbers i need
are there
right so now i'm going to say total
weights
equals um one two factorial
four factorial three factorial yeah
someone got a number for me
288. lovely okay
so this is not complicated if you think
about it in a logical
way now like i said could you get away
with writing less yes you could
if you wrote this and this alone
there's a very good chance you'd get
full marks okay however
like what kinds of areas or problems do
you think you're opening yourself up to
if you go straight here any suggestion
like you could
write three factorial because the circle
without
yeah yeah instead of one times two yeah
yeah excellent okay so this three
factorial right
we know where it comes from because
we've written this down but someone
could have seen oh
um i'm around a circle and i've got four
things to do and then they just write
down
three factorial they haven't actually
taken care of all of the conditions and
that kind of thing
this is much clearer you can see i
understand because i've written all that
and my diagram makes sense
okay and also i didn't miss any things
when people write this kind of thing out
and they just go straight here they're
like they'll just forget something
because they haven't laid out everything
and checked mentally there's nothing to
check against have i accounted for
everything because it's all up here okay
so that's part a that's the easy bit now
comes the
probability part so have a look at what
it's asking now
one rower and one cricketer are related
given these conditions what's the
probability that these two members of
the community will sit next to each
other
so here's part b okay so
luckily for me everything that i've
already done still applies and now i
just want to add an extra layer to it
okay
so um that's interesting all right so
we're going with this
now have a look at my setup have a look
at my setup i've got the four
objects placed around the table
it's the rower and the cricketer who are
related okay the rower
and the cricketer okay so where could
one of the cricketers sit well
for instance they could sit over here
here's a spot
for one of the quickest to see it now if
this is where the cricket is sitting
i now have an additional condition that
the rowers have to sit in
right where's the related one going to
be they have to be
here right remember there's um four
rowers right there's four rollers
and this cricket sorry this roller has
to be here otherwise you won't meet the
condition that we've just added
right are there any other things that
need to apply
that's it right so look back at what
we've done
right some of this is relevant and some
of it is not okay
uh is this still relevant
yeah yep still good i have to i have to
get someone seated first it didn't have
to be the rowers there could be anyone
is this still relevant yes the
basketball is still stuck how about this
one
ah so i locked someone in position right
so i'm going to forget about this one
for a second
what about this one huh
it's different now isn't it because i
locked one of the rowers in position
so now there's only three spots for the
other rowers to rearrange themselves
right so first i've already said okay
this is only one
this is going to be three factorial
right what about this one is this one
still relevant
yeah it is isn't it they're still good
right
okay i'm not finished yet remember where
i started with was to lock this guy in
position
right but clearly this is not the only
place the cricketer can sit
yeah he can sit over here so if i put
him
uh nuts and crosses let's put him here
instead okay
now where is his um what was it are they
brothers or something they're just
related okay
where's the other cricketer going to go
has to be here
okay now you can see just by the
symmetry of how i've drawn this
the number of ways to arrange the
naught's arrangement is exactly the same
as the number of ways to do the
crosses arrangement yeah i've already
worked that out so i can say
total weights gonna be equal to
um one position for the basketball is
one position for the cricketer once i've
locked him in
three factorial ways for the remaining
rowers
three factorial ways for the basketballs
who don't give a rip in this particular
set of conditions
and those cricketers can actually swap
places
and that's fine okay
now just having a look at this you can
actually go ahead and you can work out i
think this is going to be
that's 6 times 6 which is 36 that's 72
looks like it's a quarter of this right
so it's
72 so therefore the probability
is
which is a coil